the Senate has pivoted from one of the
most contentious partisan periods in the
nation's history to passing this rescue
package 100 nothing hours ago the Senate
unanimously passed the two point I think
2.2 trillion dollar stimulus relief bill
for millions of Americans impacted by
the corona virus no one has not been
impacted that relief package now heads
to the house so what can we expect
nobody no better person to ask
now then Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
who joins us now Kevin the ball is yours
96 Oh from the Senate where does it
house stand on this well I believe the
house will pass this bill we want to
make sure we're able to read it the
final text did not come out till last
night remember the size and the scope of
how much money this is so we will take
the opportunity to read through it today
we will vote on Friday tomorrow in the
morning but the floor will look
different remember where we are today we
have a number of members who have the
virus on both sides of the aisle we have
a number of members who are quarantined
we have challenges for flying here
because some flights are being canceled
so you might not have the full body but
you want to make sure you have the
debate and those constituents have their
voices it will pass but this time not
with the unanimous consent with no
debate we'll have a debate and then
we'll have a voice vote to bring it up
and move it to the President's desk
unfortunately we have wasted this entire
week because the Democrats wanted to put
in their election law changes bailout
pensions put the green New Deal we were
able to keep that out but they did put
some more funding for things that don't
deal with coronavirus but we will still
get this package that is needed for the
hospitals right for the for the small
businesses to keep people employed
that's the key part here and every day
matters so we want to get this done
quickly I love the fact that it's an
incentive
these are loans these are grants unless
you do not effort to keep 90 percent of
your employees then they become loans
you got to pay them back so there's an
incentive to keep people in and on the
job I love that when you're coming in
people might be thinking themselves okay
that's a Republican coming in
criticizing a Democrat but you're
actually being act one drew percent
accurate with no
political agenda Nancy Pelosi came in
demanding mandatory early voting ballot
harvesting provisions on EPA standards
over the next 20 years for airplanes
Planned Parenthood financing and she did
get some stuff but not all this stuff
what did that do to the money that the
American people are waiting for well
it's very frustrating because if you are
a small business owner that's what I was
you're sitting around a kitchen table
right now trying to make a decision do
you lay people off or not what this is
this is help on the way
when this passes you can not only just
get a loan but if you keep paying your
employees and paying your rent that
portion of it is forgiven you don't pay
it back it's the incentive to keep
America working because so many millions
of us work in a small business and for a
larger business meaning that you have
more than 500 employees we're going to
provide you the loan guarantee but we
also have a tax incentive in there where
we could pay up to 50 percent of your
employees for those two months we want
to keep America working that makes us
stronger but we also deal with on an
unemployment insurance now the one thing
about Nancy Pelosi there she didn't get
that stuff in the bill she plussed up
more money for things that weren't
dealing with coronavirus but that's the
pain that we had to put up for three
days of not getting this bill moved
right she did get twenty five million
dollars for the Kennedy Center think
about how that would have benefited
hospitals also small businesses now have
to stay out of union organization
efforts so she got that and what does
that have to do with anything to do with
this package there real quick
congressman they're saying they're going
back for a fourth and fifth senator
Blumenthal among others says what we
didn't get here we'll get on the fourth
and fifth rounds are we expecting two
more rounds of trillion-dollar rescue
packages you know I take a deep breath
we've just now passed this would be the
third bill let's let this work let's
let's this work inside America because I
know the ingenuity the intensity and the
inspiration we have can overcome this we
have now given the resources to make and
solve this problem
we don't need to be crafting another
bill right now let's let these two
trillion dollars go to work for us
plus the eight billion ahead of time and
the billions of dollars that we just
passed on the second bill yeah we just
have to find a way to get sick
remote voting for Senator Thune and the
other and Senator Rand Paul not to be
able to participate in the big picture
and the twenty in the year of 2020 I
think we can handle that but we're out
for now let's get through this week and
we'll hopefully get a passage on Friday
leader McCarthy thanks for telling us
the latest news appreciate it thank you
and remember we will overcome this and
we will be stronger